in this video I'm going to talk about
one of my favorite philosophers of all
time somebody who is not all that
well-known but who I think deserves to
be much better known this very
systematic comprehensive and deeply
incisive philosopher whose name is
Maurice Blondell this is one of his
major early works
accion 1893 and it was actually his
dissertation one of his two
dissertations back at that time you know
- right - for for the French
philosophical establishment he and I
actually wrote my dissertation on race
blown now I can't rightly say that I've
had a blown DeLeon phase the way I could
talk about a start trim phase or an
itching phase or Hegelian phase or
things like that
in part because blown Dowell is still
absolutely central in my my thinking
he's one of the interlocutors who I
retain the engaged like Aristotle or
Plato our Epictetus really also Hegel
people who I'm going to be thinking
through probably the rest of my my life
and career is a philosopher and so I
want to tell you a little bit about who
this guy was and you know some of his
story and his influence and importance
and I'll tell you a little bit about his
philosophy as well just very you know
thumbnail sketch stuff because it's it's
quite complex and and very you know
difficult to try to encapsulate in a few
moments but I won't start out talking
about how I got into blown del in the
first place because it was very
fortuitous or you know depending on how
you want to look at it you might say
providential so when I was in graduate
school I've done a video about the
languages that I acquired and used for
my research Greek Latin German and
French and one of the ways that you
could actually pass a language
requirement at SIU was at least for
philosophy was to translate a work from
the original language
and then you wouldn't have to take
coursework or stuff like that I was
actually taking graduate level courses
in French just just for kicks just you
know literature classes not in
philosophy or anything like that so I
thought well you know I've got a good
facility with French I'll translate
something and the guy who did French
philosophy there was Garth Gillen who
eventually became my mentor and
dissertation adviser and a good friend
of mine and I can tell you much more
about about my interactions with him and
in another video but this actually did
have to do with some important
interactions so Garth had taught a class
on Adorno then I took my second semester
at SIU and I really enjoyed it I enjoy
it a toreador knows works they're very
complex very difficult to read they're
very demanding and he's critical of
everything and anything but it's he's
also a great stylist so it's very
interesting to read him and Garth was
also very much into Holocaust Studies as
a matter of fact he has a book called
after Auschwitz reason the true the good
I think it's after Auschwitz the rising
from the ruins that's what it is reason
reason true and the good after after
Auschwitz and so I knew that and I
thought well I'll do something having to
do with the Holocaust of d'Or know so I
went to the library and I think I just
dug around in the Revue de metaphase he
hated morality or some other French
journals and I found something recent
some piece a Holocaust and Adorno in
French and so I thought perfect I'll
translate this you'll like that and then
he'll sign off on it and and all that so
he was passing outside the hallway and I
was sitting in my office with my feet up
on my desk and I saw him say hey hey
I've got something for you
I've got it I've got a piece I'm gonna
translate from my French apartment he
said well what is it so he handed it to
him he's a tall
no this their this stuff is a dime a
dozen if you're going to translate
something translate something that
actually needs to be translated and so
you know his idea was and this is quite
true
look there's a ton of material out there
that really deserves to be translated
into English and nobody's done it and
nobody's probably going to do it unless
somebody comes along and happens to find
an interest in that and say yeah I'll do
this so I said well who-who should I
translate them and he thought for a
minute they said Maurice blown down and
I said well I've never heard of him so
he's a French Catholic thinker early
20th century influenced merleau-ponty
gars was a variant Merrill Ponte and
phenomenology and the interesting thing
about this was that garthe he spoke as
if he thought about this real long time
but actually he was speaking really spur
the moment he had just happened to read
a reference to Rome he hadn't actually
read blown nel for years and years and
years and the only book of blown bells
that he had read at that point it was
was accion 1893 blown doll had sort of a
currency in certain Catholic circles up
until right about maybe the 70s and then
he sort of fell outta sight in large
part anyway garthe was Darth had read a
little bit about him and garthe
adrenaline stew him that very day and so
garthe yeah that most of blown down
stuff hasn't been translated you should
translate some of that so what should I
translate I don't know find something
and translated so I went to the library
and thankfully at SIU in an amazing
research library particularly when I
compare it to other research libraries
that I had been to you know some
top-notch schools that don't have all
the holdings in certain things and they
had then all these works by blown down
and at that time the they had begun
republishing blown Del's really works so
I said well I'll start with some of the
earliest stuff and so I got the volume
from the president of Air cetera to
France and blown Nels early works and
just started translating and the what
ended up happening was I translated wow
this happened to me twice it's like
translated a good portion of what ends
up being this word now this isn't my
translation this is a translation that's
been out for a long time by Drew and
Trethowan and it's part of the resource
of all series a great great series by by
eerdmans and it's got two works and at
the letter around apologetics and
history and dogma I'll talk about those
in just just a few minutes when I talk
about balloon Dells thought so luckily
before I had gone too far into it I
found the that somebody had already
translated it so and and I was just sort
of I was working my way through Blondell
I was kind of learning as I was
translating and I was fascinated by his
thought because it was just it was just
amazing stuff but it was very complex
his writing is rather turgid and and you
know it's this vast systematic
discussion of things so it is rather
difficult to render well I mean it's not
even great French quite honestly there
was a critic and I forgot who it was
that said that Blondell actually needed
to be translated into French and the guy
wrote French in the first place so you
know that that's you know that's a sign
so then I settled on on translating
another piece called the idealist
illusion and I worked up a translation
of that and I was going to
you know I had a first draft and I was
gonna see if there was anything about it
and then fiak were long brought out the
idealist illusion and other essays and
luckily I happened to find out about it
because I would have really embarrassed
myself trying to send this off to a
publisher would have said well you know
there's already a translation up there
so it was a good way to get to know
blown-down them I loved translating in
part because you have to give voice to
another author instead of trying to say
your own thing or articulate your own
thoughts you've already got somebody
who's pretty brilliant and at least what
you're doing you know philosophical
translation and they're saying something
that's worth talking about and you've
got to you've got to work your way into
it and figure out how to express this
not just to students that's what
teaching is about but to speakers of
another language and so it really makes
you learn their works anyway long story
short I became more and more interested
in blown-down at that time I was
considering by the time that I was doing
all of this work I was considering
writing my dissertation first under edad
I was talked out of that by Stephen
Timon thank God who said you should
write on somebody a perennial
philosophical Court so now I'll do some
talk about my Didion phase that I went
through another time and then I shifted
to Hegel and I thought yeah I'm gonna
write on Hegel I'm gonna work on him
he's he's certainly somebody who's doing
me something that that's going to stand
the test of time thoughts worth worth
definitely worth thinking out
making your own and figuring out how
they apply to your own life and practice
and all that now long Dell was called
the French Hegel or the Catholic Hegel
for good reason
his work is it has two things in common
well three though three things in common
with with Hegel action for the fourth is
that he started to read and you almost
need a concordance sometimes to make
your way through some of the stuff until
you've learned that the past Blondell is
a systematic thinker so this book you
know
accion 1883 it's you know it's a it's
called an essay on a critique of life
and a science of practice and it's it's
organized into all these chapters and he
analyzes action the concept the
phenomenon the reality of action its
constituents what it requires what it
points us towards moving from the
simplest things all the way up to
politics religion culture history all
those sorts of things so that sounds an
awful lot like Hegel - doesn't Blondell
was also a dialectical philosopher
similar to Hegel in fact I would say is
actually more dialectical than than than
Hegel he's taken the dialectic further
than than Hegel did Hegel wasn't
dialectic enough that's a common
complaint made about Hegel by his his
ears like you know somebody like Marx
you know materialist blown Dallas
tearing it in a very different way and
so those are two main ways in which he's
like Hegel there's also the the
difficulty of reading his writing the
other the other thing is that blown nel
ultimately is steering you towards some
sort of final place in which philosophy
is going to fully realize itself and he
understood this as something that
is gonna draw on the resources of
philosophy develop you know from
antiquity on but which came to a
particularly crisis moment in this
period that we call modernity so blown
dealt thought that modern thought modern
ways of living modern culture presents
us with radically new challenges and
this is very similar to Hegel it's also
similar to somebody like like Nietzsche
or Heidegger and by the way Heidegger
actually thought very highly of blown
down and sent Ernesto Grassi one of his
students actually one time to convey
those those sentiments to him so I was
very attracted to just the breadth and
the scope of blow and Ellis thought he
was a philosopher for philosophers who
analyzed everybody else's philosophy and
tried to try to show you tried to push
it as far as it could go and show where
it revealed itself to be inadequate and
requiring something beyond it and he did
the all of this through what we could
call the metaphysics of charity and I
don't mean charity in the sense of like
doling out you know money to people I
mean charity in the Christian conception
of love I got paid which is with Caritas
is a translation of you have to if
you're going to be a good philosopher in
one Dells view you have to be able to
love even the people that you disagree
with
and the comportment that's required for
a thinker is to treat everybody with you
know utmost fairness and see whether
there really is anything to their their
point of view their doctrine their their
system there are criticisms of other
people and push them as far as they can
go even push them beyond where they are
comfortable with being it's kind of
Augustinian love in that case and then
see what else has to be added to
picture to fill it in blown del
understood philosophy and religion as
necessarily coming into crisis and
conflict in modernity because both of
them and this is where his understanding
of philosophy is very different than
that of contemporary continental or
contemporary analytic philosophy because
philosophy is and has been and ought to
be something that tries to describe
everything it tries to bring everything
within its purview it tries to describe
integral reality so does religion
philosophy makes absolute claims
religion makes absolute claims are they
necessarily going to conflict or can
they interviews with each other in fact
do they need to interviews with each
other in order for the philosophy to be
realized in order for and in this case
Christianity be due to be realized
that's the argument that that Blondell
makes in Locke's show and also in
history of dogma and the letter on
apologetics and a number of his his
other works so I found this this point
of view very compelling and then you
know I started studying more and more
about people writing about blown-down
and more and more of glendale's works
themselves and the more that I studied
you know reading this stuff in the
French and you know some of the
secondary literature in German and some
of it I can puzzle out and Italian at
least the sections I needed to I just
got drawn in more and more and more
people talk about blown Dells work as
being cycloidal as you know working
around these center points and drawing
you in further
further further and that that really
isn't and blone del talks about the will
he talks about desire he talks about
community he talks about all these
themes that I was particularly
interested in at the time you know the
relation between faith and reason and he
staked out a position that was that was
radically new and yet in continuity with
with past thinkers it's interesting this
is a side note I'll come back to my main
discussion in a moment it's interesting
that in Catholic circles blown devil is
almost unknown outside of Catholic
circles that wasn't the case prior to
World War two he was a major force in
French philosophy he influenced along
with their song phenomenology mock
Schaller invited him to to be part of
the constant he in at blundell you know
turned him down
Heidegger like I pointed out knew who
the guy was that one of his his students
to you know talk to him William James
you know interacted with blown-down he
was one of the big heavy hitters of
early of late 19th century and early
20th century French philosophy at least
as important as on Revere's own or or
any of the other people that you could
compare him to at the time in Catholic
circles
Blondell became embroiled in what was
called the modernist controversy and
this was something that really got its
per from a document called the path
Shandy and then the lament ability from
Pope Pius the tenth which to find this
this heresy of modernism which was you
know connected with with contemporary
philosophy and
theological studies and biblical studies
and all these sorts of things and there
actually were modernists at the time
because blown-down interacted with them
and told them how they were wrong and in
you know the letter on apologetics of
history of dogma he's keen to sort of
say well look the old way you can't just
say we're going to regurgitate Thomas
Aquinas and that'll solve everything we
have to think things out in radically
new ways at the same time this has to be
in continuity with with the past and you
can't just throw it away and say well
it's it sort of all up for grabs or you
know there were a lot of different
things to I'm going to sort of skip
through the story through it fairly
quickly in any case there were a certain
Thomas like Gary gula garage for example
who admitted that he did not understand
blown Dells work at all he said I've
read it and I can't understand it who
consistently attacked blown down as a
modernist and so within Catholic circles
and very you know conservative Catholic
circles he's if you say you're a blown
down person they think you're your
heterodox the irony is is that those of
us who are still around as blown down
scholars tend to be on the more
traditional you know even cancer fix
side of things
blown Nels thought led to Vatican two
and through several different paths he
influenced all of the nouvelle tlg
people I got ready to luboc you know
John Donoghue he also influenced the
transcendental Thomas from from Irish
all all the way to Ron ER and then later
on Lonnegan he Simone called him the
philosopher of Vatican two for good
reason or maybe it was King Savior right
and maybe mixing those two up in any
case I had come back to the the church
because of the intellectual tradition
that I found there and this was at the
same time that you know John Paul the
second is coming out with fetus a trot
CEO and talking about all these these
great things a lot of powerful movement
of thought going on at the time and so
blown doll had been you know thinking
about these issues a hundred years
before that and so I I you know I
latched onto this and I saw this as
being really really central I would like
to also make one other digression point
out a book that I think is particularly
worth getting your hands on if you want
to know anything about Maurice
blown-down it's by the guy who actually
translated this he was the second
translator of Axio 1993 the first
translation was not very good all of a
blast shot at BA at Boston College has
taught blown down for decades I almost
said centuries and decades and he's
actually still still doing quite well I
met him at a conference recently and I
was a little star-struck because this is
a guy who I corresponded with you know
back when I first started studying
blowing down he is sort of like he's the
grandfather of blown doll studies here
in the United States in any case he
recently came out with a book that I
actually reviewed in a journal
Maurice bloom della philosophical life
if you want to know about the guy and
you want to see the context of loaned
Allen his time this is this is a book
that's you you just have to have there's
a few other great blown delve books that
I could bring up as well but I'm gonna
I'm gonna skip over that for the time
being so I wrote my dissertation on
blown down
and that ended up taking me about three
years to research and write and I really
enjoyed it I think I overreached quite a
bit I tried to analyze three major
conceptions in blown Dells thoughts and
each one of them probably would have
would reach one of them probably merits
its own book and then I tried to tie it
in also with this you know massive
discussion of Catholic intellectual life
and thought in in the 20th century
beginning with the Posche nd ending with
fetus Iran Co and it was very ambitious
totally unpublishable but a great great
exercise great time for me to work on on
this and not only to read Blondell and
meditate on his thought and try to work
it through but also to see what other
people were writing and talking about
when it came to blown-down and I had a
few conference papers some of which
became Articles that came out of that
period later on I would actually do
something different with blown-down and
that's that's where most of my work on
him is bad in the last say six years and
this ties in with the the Christian
philosophy debates stuff that is the
subject of my first book Blondell got
involved in this debate in the 1930s
about the Christian philosophy about the
possibility the reality the nature of
Christian philosophy people were using
the term and some people said look that
doesn't mean anything there's no such
thing as Christian philosophy if it's
Christian can't be philosophy if it's
philosophy can't be Christian other
people said you know whole variety of
other positions some of Thomas's
Christian philosophy but you know
providing you just rigidly distinguish
the theology from the philosophy of
course nobody could agree on where the
dividing lines were and I got very very
complex drew in about about 50 or 60
different
French intellectuals some of them
secular what we would now call
secularists many of them Catholic quite
a few of them actually reformed
Protestant and then it spurred a later
French reformed Protestant debate in the
1940s and 50s and it's it spilled over
in other areas and it comes up now and
again in different spots in any case
this this colleague of mine Adrian paps
sent me some documents that blonde Ellen
written in the debates and said why
don't why don't you translate this stuff
and I thought well you know I wanted to
translate blown-down for quite a while
and I actually have a draft of his his
1927 work path through a team on EJ just
sitting there that I haven't done
anything with for years I should polish
it up and send it out and I began trying
to translate one of his one of the books
of his later metaphysical trilogy that
is at being and beings which is the
third the second book in that the third
volume it's five volume three three book
set and this was more manageable this
was like smaller articles and I thought
yeah okay I could I could do that and so
I started researching it and as it
turned out in in English language
literature the debates had been you know
the debates are like this big and they
saw like this little bit event not when
they were going on and when they were
going out and they saw this much but
over time they got shrunk and shrunk and
shrunk and so after a while the people
that are you know in the Catholic
circles talking about this well it's
just a debate between Jocelyn Mara Tom
Brady
maybe none Steenburgen no I included
blown-down was another another major
thing Gabrielle Marcel continents their
tianj and all these other thinkers in
French Catholic Catholic and Protestant
intellectual life writing back and forth
it even spilled into Germany into some
Italian stuff some some Spanish stuff
started you know spurred some discussion
here in the States and in Canada and
Bloedel was one of the central figures
this was one of the major documents from
the work still untranslated
unfortunately maybe not maybe I'll
translate it in the future if I if I get
around to it find the time there was
talk a while back of starting a blowing
dial translation project I much rather
be part of a blown Bell translation
project then try to translate this stuff
just all by myself because there's a
whole bunch of reasons one is it's
better to translate with other people
because you know you go back and forth
it's a lot more fun translating with
other people it's a lot easier to get
things done and it's easier to stand on
point and not get lost in the forest
when you're doing that well anyway he
not only wrote this book he wrote a
number of important articles and I
translated four of those along with
another eight other articles or pieces
as the main body of my my first my first
book which came out with Catholic
University of America Press a few years
back 2011 called the reason fulfilled by
revelation the 1930s Christian
philosophy debates in France and so I
was trying to give blown Dells voice
back I was trying to bring him back into
the spotlight and show that he was just
as central to the debate as people whose
works have been translated like a
schedule saw or Jacque more attend or a
meal per year right here stuff has been
translated
mainly his history of philosophy and so
I I got drawn into that aspect of
Glendale in the last several years since
that book has been published I had been
spending more time going back to other
other things in blown-down going back to
the metaphysical trilogy going back to
accion 1893 you know this first early
work also going back to another thing
that I really enjoyed this is called the
Carnot and team
these are his notebooks that he he
journaled in as he was working out his
dissertation as he was thinking about it
and it was part of a spiritual practice
for him it's it's really interesting to
see his thought developing so I don't I
don't know exactly what I'm gonna do
with blowing down other than to think
along with him I can tell you this that
within the next year or two and there's
a few other projects I want to get out
of the way I am going to do a youtube
series specifically on boxing on 1893
going through the entire book I think I
will probably wait until I've done
Hegel's phenomenology of spirit before I
do that because I promise to do that but
but blown delta's definitely deserves to
be well known he's been extremely
fruitful for my thought he's been
somebody I've learned a lot from
oftentimes things that changed me in the
process for the better because I was
able to recognize my own failings as a
philosopher as a thinker and as a friend
as a father as a boyfriend fiance
husband blown doll has been somebody
very good for for helping me think about
what I want to do and and again his
thought is so rich so complex
it's it's easy to sort of get lost in it
and just you know be struck with wha the
way one often does with with Hegel as
well so I could I could talk for hours
about this but but I think I should draw
this to a close at this point I'm sure
that some of you will have questions or
comments about this and welcome them and
I'll try to respond to all of them